so if you're sitting in this room you
are probably a software engineer and
you're probably familiar with a little
tool called git you probably use git to
manage your source code with your team
and the way you probably use it is
something along the lines of typing out
a few basic commands that you know that
usually work most of the time and when
something goes wrong you head over to
Google copy and paste the first thing
you find paste it into your command
prompt and it works and all as well my
hope with this talk is that we'll be
able to learn a little bit more about
how git works under the hood we're gonna
discover kit internals and what happens
when you execute some of the most common
commands that you work with so when
using the git version control system
this talk is going to be heavily
command-line focused and my goal is that
I'll show you examples of some of the
kind of outputs you'll see when you
execute git commands and what those
outputs mean and what's happening under
the hood but before we go under the hood
I want to travel back into the past I'm
a bit of a computer history junkie and I
always think that we tend to repeat
patterns in the field of computing and
we can look to the Past to pick up on
some really interesting trends so let's
travel to the past we're going to travel
to the Year 1972 a little place called
Bell Labs which does a lot of
interesting things in 1970s one of them
which was creating the source code
control system it was a version control
system that they architected at that
time and it consisted of three basic
things a deltal table a set of control
and tracking flags and a set of control
records and the Delta table as you might
expect was a data structure that held
deltas between changes and files keep
that in mind as we talked a little bit
about what's going to change in the
future
there are also control and tracking
clocks that were used to set permissions
and release controls on specific files
control records that they use to keep
track of insertions and deletions at the
file level all of this was being created
and this terminology was being set up in
the 1970s SCSS was a pretty popular
version control system at Bell Labs
until around 1982 when another kick tool
came along and it was called the
revision control system now one of the
key things that we'll need to point out
about the revision control system was
that I was not distributed at all it was
used to maintain a version code on a
single machine
there was no client-server relationship
and it wasn't decentralized did one
pretty basic thing a kept track of the
history of changes to a set of files in
a source code system and this was the
state of source code management until
the year 1990 and the release of
something called the concurrent version
system just commonly known as CVS and
CVS was different from RVC because it
employed a client-server model and a
copy of the repository would be stored
on some sort of central machine and
several clients could make copies of it
and interact with that central machine
and at that point in time in the 90s it
was possible for multiple people to make
changes to the same file and what
happens when multiple people are editing
the same file well they disagree on some
things and you get a little something
called a large conflict which occurs
when different individuals make the
different changes to the same file and
you have to resolve this March
whenever you get large conflicts you
have to have some sort of heuristic or
technique for resolving them how do you
reconcile differences and what the final
code should be and CVS a strategy was
that if you ever wanted to make a commit
or make a change to something you always
had to pull in the most recent changes
before you made that commit so the way
it resolved merge conflicts was by
making sure they never happened in the
first place because you had to commit on
the most recent four
of your team's codebase and that was the
status quo for around the until around
the year 2005 when this little thing
called get came along it was different
from its predecessors because it was
decentralized in nature if you think
about it it still is decentralized in
nature you can have multiple first class
copies of a repository in different
places you have a first class copy of
your team's codebase on your developer
machine that you're working with right
now there's also a copy that exists on
github servers or get lab servers
there's a copy that exists on your
continuous integration built all of
these are distributed first-class copies
of that same repository this was a
unique model at that time and
furthermore github get had a different
technique for resolving merge conflicts
you didn't need to be on the latest
version of a codebase before making a
change you could be working on an old
version make some changes and then pull
in the new versions changes and
reconcile them then that was pretty new
for the time it was released in 2005 and
at that time it was very new but raise
your hand if you use git at your
organization that's pretty much
everybody in the room there's a lot of
opinions and ideas around how git came
to be so popular some might say that I
had a really great strategy for
resolving merge conflicts and for
managing branches that was really
appealing to a lot of developers another
reason is it had a very big first early
adopter the Linux kernel code base was
one of the first code bases to be
managed with git so right away there was
a group of people using it then you had
the emergence of a little web
application or piece of software some of
us might be familiar with called github
that accelerated its popularity so
regardless of what the reasons are
forget becoming pretty ubiquitous and
developers workflows it's on your
machine and you
interacting with it everyday but what's
actually going on here so we're gonna
start with the first point of
interaction that most developers will
have when they're working with get let's
say you started a new job or you've
started contributing to a new open
source project well you're gonna run
this command git clone here I'm cloning
the interact repository and you can see
that there's all this business about
objects and deltas and compressing and
enumerate and resolving and what's going
on here how many of you have seen this
output before and either ignored it or
bent like slightly confused about it
yeah we're gonna find out and the way
we're gonna find out is by looking
through a special directory that exists
on every get version managed project ooh
that was a bad way of saying that that
exists on every repository that you're
managing with git and nicely enough it's
called the dot git directory so well
notice here that it's got a couple of
different directories the one that I'm
really interested in is objects because
we saw that word in the last slide just
talking about writing objects and
compressing objects so let's see if we'd
I went there if you'll see anything okay
that's interesting so if we take a look
inside our objects directory it looks
like we've got two more directories one
of them is called info and the other one
is called pack okay let's see what's
inside those directories or just diving
deeper okay this is interesting there is
nothing in our info directory but there
is something in our pack directory
there's one file that's got an ID X
extension and there is another file
that's got this dog pack extension now
as it turns out these are binary files
so we can't poke into them by running
cat to print the outputs instead we'll
use a tool or a command called file to
get some more details about these files
so you can see from this output that we
have a pack file which is described as a
gift pack version two file that stores
about 50
thousand objects okay that's interesting
then we've got this other file which is
an index file it's also interesting so
I've been throwing this word objects
around a lot and you're probably really
perplexed at this point but this is
great because I'm about to explain what
they are right on this next slide so
objects and the get contacts are data
types that consists of three things they
have a type a size and some contents and
there are four types of objects that
exist in the get context you have blobs
these are objects that are used to
represent file data you have trees these
are objects that are used to reference
multiple blobs or multiple trees you can
think of them sort of like a folder it's
a folder that contains references to
multiple their files or more trees you
have objects that are commits which
contain a reference to a particular tree
and they also contain things like the
timestamp at which a commit was made the
committer and the commit message
associated with that commit and the
fourth type of object that you'll see is
an annotated tag object this happens if
you cut a release or create a tag and
get you will get a tag object and it
contains a lot of the same details that
you'll see in your commit object it
contains a message a timestamp and the
person who created that tag so these are
the four kinds of objects that we're
gonna be working with when we're looking
inside its internals all of this might
seem super nebulous right now but as we
dive further we're gonna be able to see
what's stored in these actual objects
and how they all connect together so
what's really interesting is the size of
that dot pack file that we just pulled
is about 17 megabytes now to give you
some context that project I cloned is a
project that uses a mono repo
architecture which means that it's one
github repository we want to get
repository but multiple
subfolders and sub projects are stored
within it it's a project that's been
around for about four years it's got
about I don't know how many commits I'll
have to look that up it's got quite a
few commits it's got quite a few files
that's a big project but somehow all of
that data that we have on it managed to
be compressed into 17 megabytes we're
going to look into how that happens and
just a little bit now let's say you've
started this new job you've cloned your
team's code into your new computer and
you've been tasked with an assignment
somebody tells you alright here's an
issue go make a fix or go at this
feature well what's the first thing that
you're gonna do you're probably going to
create a new branch using this command
here get checkout B and then you're
gonna give it a branch name in this case
the branch name I gave it was Sofia my
new branch great so standard output says
here that we've switched to a new branch
called Sofia my new branch but what's
actually happening under the hood once
again we're gonna go back to our source
of truth which is our git directory and
we're gonna see what we can find
yeah I think that's really intriguing
here is this file called head because
sometimes usually will end up executing
the command called git push origin head
who's run that command before yeah
what's the head let's see what we can
see inside that file oh this is
interesting
so within the contents of the head file
we see that there is a reference to
another file which is located that refs
heads Sofia why new branch ok that's
kinda cool by the way side note one of
the things I'm really into lately is
structuring my get branches by
separating it out with like afford slash
so it prints out really neatly when I do
this so then you can do like Sofia and
then like what month I created the
branch in or what day and just be
completely neurotic about it unpacked
all right so we've got a reference to
this my new branch file what's going on
here let's see if we can print that out
all right so I just bring it out the
file and here we see a 40 character
sha-1 hash how many of you have seen
these hashes when you're working with
skin yeah what the heck is going on here
so I want to show you something magical
that you can do whenever you see a sha-1
hash as you're working around get code
you can print out the file but you you
can print out the object that's
associated with it so here I'm invoking
a git command called cat file which is
basically asking it to print out the
contents of the object associated with
that hash and here we can see that the
the hash that I printed is referring to
a commit object because we can see it's
got some information about the author
the committer and then we've got the
commit message right there and that
commit file references AIT's tree object
which is on the first one one thing to
capture is that this particular commit
has to parents keep that in mind because
I'm gonna answer why in a little bit I
like to do this cuz it keeps you on the
edge of your seats
I don't want anybody believe the room so
yeah so now we have got this new branch
and we know that it's a branch starting
off the latest commit that we branched
off of now usually what you're gonna do
is you're going to make a change to a
file or something in that repository so
let's say that I made a change to the
readme file in this repository I made
that change and then I ran it add now
I'm gonna skip a few of the details here
but when you make a new and you make a
modification to a file and you run git
add that file is staged for commit what
does that mean it means that a new blob
object is created that corresponds to
that file and blobs are one of the four
types of option
that exists indicate ecosystem that I
mentioned earlier are used to represent
file data now you can fetch the hash
associated with that blob object and
print it out by running cat file so this
is truncated but when you print out the
hash or you print out the object
associated with that hash what you're
actually printing out is the entire
contents of that readme file with the
change that you just staged so whenever
you run get add you're adding a new blob
object to your dotted directory with the
modified file for every file that you've
changed that's a lot of data you can
imagine you're always adding files to
your get repository to manage and every
time you do that you're creating a new
blob object how is all of that data
stored and how is it compressed is one
thing that I'll answer in a little bit
oh I love keeping on the edge of your
seats all right so next thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to commit the change
you know with the change using the
commit - update readme can't and what
I've done here is I ran the tree command
on the get directory before and after
running the change and what I've shown
you here is the diff so some of the new
files that were added inside the objects
directory and you can see that there's
two new files or sorry two new files the
one in directory 26 and the one in
directory DC so this is like a really
weird thing that you'll notice when
you're looking at the object structuring
it you have a hash that's 40 characters
and you haven't hash created for every
time you staged an object to make commit
and so on what is this weird business
about making the directory name the
first two letters of the hash and then
the other 38 characters are used for the
actual file name it's kind of it seems a
little unnecessary the reasoning behind
it is actually two the first is their
operating systems that have a limit
on the number of files that you can have
within a directory so for example if
you're on a modern Mac OS system
I think the limit for the number of
files you have can happen a directory
before your machine is kind of riots
against you is 1.2 billion now that's a
lot but in other operating systems there
are more stringent limits on the number
of files that you can have within a
directory so by separating out out into
the structure you reduce the number of
files that can exist within a single
directory there's another reasoning
which is performance related usually
when you're navigating the file system
especially in Exe file systems which are
used in a lot of Linux operating systems
you browse files on a per directory
basis so whenever you're searching for a
file you have to look through all other
files in that directory and by using
this naming convention you break it up
into smaller directories or sub
directories with a smaller number of
files and reduce the amount of time you
have to spend searching for objects in
your file system so that's the reasoning
so really quickly we're gonna go and cut
out the object associated with that ec2
two-one-two all right so it looks like
it is a commit object oh you can see
that here because again it's got the
message it's got the committer which is
me and it's got a reference to a tree
object let's see if we can print that
out they'll do the same thing here we'll
use the cat file command and this is an
example of what a tree object looks like
remember earlier I mentioned that a tree
object is essentially referencing other
blobs or other tree objects well you can
see that here I've got an es lint or C
file that is a blob object that's being
referenced I don't know if I've got a
directory there yes I've got a style
guide of directory that's being
referenced as a tree object so all of
that is the state of my repository
stored as a single object awesome so
what essentially happen here
is we made a change to our readme file
we staged that change by running get out
when we staged that change a new blob
object was created to capture that
change that was the blob object that we
printed out a couple of slides back and
then we committed that change and when
we committed it we created a new commit
object that referenced a new tree object
that had a reference to that same commit
hash so that decisi that was the same
blob object that we printed out a couple
of slides back people following me if
you're not by the way feel free if
you're confused to ask questions on the
slide do and I'll be happy to answer
them at the end of this or just in
person afterwards all right so you
cloned a copy of your company's
repository onto your local machine you
created a new branch that you made a
change on and you committed that change
well now it's time to push that change
up everyone has probably executed this
can before I referenced it earlier it's
the git push origin head command alright
now we're seeing all of this business
about like deltas and compressions and
objects and all of this stuff so what's
going on here well the first thing
that's going on here is that it has
compressed some of those loose objects
that we created in our repository into
that pack file that we saw earlier so
imagine this you're working on a file
it's called your readme file you make a
change to that file you staged it and
you commit it you make another change to
that file
it may be a small change and you stage
it and commit it again what's the result
you have to blob objects and to commit
objects but those two blob objects you
have that represent file data the
difference between them is miniscule it
might be the single sentence or single
word that you changed that's taking up a
lot of space that you don't
so this phase get compresses all of
those objects into a single pack file
and the heuristic that it uses to
execute this compression as follows it
starts by going through your objects
directory and still sorting the files
first by type so whether it's a commit
whether it's a blob whether it's a tree
or whether it's attack then it sorts
them by me so it gets all of the files
that are similarly named in essence the
same file next to each other and then it
sorts them by size and this is a really
interesting thing because why would you
sort them by size because it turns out
in the next phase it uses a sliding
window to compute the deltas between
those adjacent objects and that sort and
as a sliding if it sees there's a
miniscule difference between two
adjacent objects instead of storing both
objects it'll just store one and the
Delta to the next that's what that Delta
compression thing is doing there now the
reason that it stores it by it orders it
by size this last ordering is in
reference to this law invented by the
sky that you might have heard of named
Linus
it's called Linus's law and the law
essentially states quite simply that as
time passes by the size of the file
grows and this is especially true for
source files if you think about it the
more time your company or your team is
spending writing a code base the larger
your files are I know we talked about
refactoring and keeping small files and
all that good stuff but a serial things
tend to get bigger with time and so when
you order objects by size what you're
listening about them by is recency
you're getting the most recent changes
up at the top and executing a delta on
those it's a clever heuristic that does
the job especially again if you're
working with source code files that
definitely do tend to grow with time
awesome now once these objects are
compressed we're also going to write
that index file that we saw earlier and
that index file is
essentially serves as a table of
contents that stores the hashes that we
see here and a pointer to where the
object associated with that hash is and
are compressed a pack file and that's
why you get really small get
repositories for you know projects that
are 10 years old with hundreds and
thousands of commits and hundreds of
tags released and all of this stuff it's
all compressed using this methodology
into a single pack all right so let's
say that you've made this change and now
you want to go back on to your master
branch and merge the change that you
made in your new branch onto master well
you do that by running a command called
to get merge now there's an interesting
property about this merge that we
executed which is that when we make
changes to our feature branch that was
the my new branch that I made there were
no changes made to our master branch now
this is a really fortunate case because
it means all we have to do is that cute
a fast-forward merge which means that we
had our master branch that was here we
created a new feature branch called my
new branch and we made some commits on
that branch and now we want to merge
back we don't have to do anything but
ask master to point to the new commit so
just step it forward that's why it's
called a fast-forward you're not really
having to reconcile anything you're just
changing what things point to to the
most recent commit object you have on
your new feature branch this is easy and
ideal but we write software and our
world is not ideal most of the time
so let's look through the situation
where you have made changes on your
feature branch but you've also made
changes on your master branch so now
when you go to merge there's some
reconciliation that needs to be made
because there's different commits that
exist on those timelines you know in
this case what you're going to do is
execute a recursive merge strategy and
with that you end up with a merge commit
at the head of your new branch you can
see that here it's the merge branch 11
the name of the branch that merged now
let's print out the contents of that
merge commit because as you can see
we've got the sha-1 hash for it so again
we can use our handy-dandy cat file
command if we print out the contents of
that commit object we see it's got two
parents one parent has a sha hash
starting with double zero a a and the
other has one starting with E one B now
we can go in and print out those commit
objects which is diving deeper and
deeper and we'll see that in this case
they point to the two different commits
that we made on the master branch and on
the feature branch both of those have
been reconciled into a single merge
commit with those two parents now that's
one way of merging or making sure that
you've reconciled changes in your
repository another technique that you
might be familiar with is called a
rebase and a tree base works like this
here's an example of me making a change
on a feature branch and a change on a
master branch and then I did the merge I
used to rebase to apply the changes
instead of these a merge ends up
happening here is instead of creating a
merge commit what we've done is
reconciled the changes into a single
linear history and if we actually go
through and cap out the contents of the
commit objects associated with our
commits we'll see that they both have a
single parent so you see the first
commands got one parent and the second
commit has one parent you know there's
like a lot of tension and drama
sometimes needlessly about rebasing
versus merging and this is really the
main distinct difference when you make a
merge you maintain
the explicit branching so you have an
awareness of two branches that that
merge came from and when you do a rebase
you're favoring having a linear history
having one continuous stream that you
can look back to to see all of the
changes made to your codebase and
whether or not your company uses merges
or rate basis tensage is kind of like
depending on culture and philosophy and
how you're being audited and lots of
other things that's the main distinction
between rebase and emerge so really
quickly I want to go through and cover
some of the things that we covered in
this talk so we dive into what happens
when we execute a kick clone when we
stages and get add when we commit using
commit when we push using get push we
talked a little bit about PAC files and
how get compresses the huge repository
of code that you have into a single 17
megabyte file in our case and we talked
a little bit about what happens when you
rebase and when you merge and I
underneath all that we covered the
object internals and get so something
that some key I'm gonna drink some water
before I say something weird some key
things that I want Chell to take away
from this is that it represents key
information about your repository and
the changes that happen to it as objects
that are stored in the file system
everything you need to know about git
about the history of changes made your
repository you can find in the docket
directories everything it's all there
you just have to like cat file a lot of
things and spend like three hours on it
but it's there so the next thing we know
is that get compresses loose objects all
of those blobs and commits that you
create as you're working at your code
base into a single pack file in order to
increase space efficiency and the
technique that it uses for that is
to compression using a heuristic that is
designed to sort the most recent changes
to particular files near code first and
then finally three bases and we're just
different whether they give preference
to maintaining a linear history of your
codebase or maintaining explicit
references to parent branches those are
the three things I would recommend
taking away if you're hungry for more or
I mentioned something that was like
intriguing and you want to find out more
about it don't worry I'm not gonna leave
you hanging
here's some resources the first is the
probe get book it's a text that's on the
get website it contains a lot of details
about these get internal zone and kind
of an explanation of pack files I will
admit there's really not a good
explanation of like compression the
compression technique used for
generating pack files out there I
derived most of what I knew
watching talks by Linus and then reading
old ire see logs where people would be
talking about urn you know - when it's
be explaining this like Delta
compression technique to people both Lee
the explenation I provided here was like
succinct and useful I met someone
earlier today who did a study on PEC
files as part of their mini sprint at
the recurse Center and I've posted a
link to slides they produced about pack
files here and then finally I'm a really
strange person and one of my hobbies is
like reading code basis for major
projects and annotating them and writing
blog posts about them so I looked I did
a series where I read through the get
code base and wrote a bunch of blog
posts about what I found in the gate
code base and how its structured and all
of the interesting methodologies and
techniques that I used or they used you
can find those blog posts um by going to
blog hop rocks forward slash search or a
slash get so while back I
had a friend kind of like hire me a
session with a speeding coach for my
birthday which is like a really weird
thing to give somebody for a birthday
but I liked it it was interesting and
one of the things that she told me was
that people tend to start their talks by
talking about who they are and like
dropping their credentials because
there's this fear that people won't take
you seriously and you have to like
explain all of the awesome things you've
done and then people will like hear you
out and she challenged me to drop that
need to establish my credentials at the
start and just get in on the topic and
establish my expertise by sharing what I
know and that's why my about me slide is
at the end of the talk not of the video
I'm Sophia
I maintain helped maintain a github or a
project Wow called and wrapped it's an
interactive computing experience if
you're interested in interactive
computing real-time collaboration
helping people do interesting things and
their data science workflows come talk
to me after this I'd be happy to tell
you more about what we do now you can
find out more at github comm slash
interact I co host two fun podcasts one
of them is called book bytes FM and the
other is called Jas party on book bytes
will you read technical books and just
have a book club about it we're reading
the Impostors handbook right now which
is a great text I write about tech
things on my blog which is
blog.bufferapp.com is which is like
really unfortunate for me you think it'd
be a good thing but it's not oh and then
I'm on the internet everywhere as
Captain Sophia that is my um Twitter
might github all of that stuff so if
you're interested in seeing some of the
work I'm doing you can always do that
thank you so much for coming to my
presentation
you